la radio c'était très bien rappelé par
le président de la recommande à une
valeur très importante pour nos
concitoyens c'est une valeur
individuelle et collective privée et
public contenu du fait que c'est 40
millions de Français qui l'écoutent tous
les jours c'est 93 % des Français qui
l'écoutent chaque mois c'est un média
qui sert aussi en cas de crise c'est un
des plus résilients qui permet une
communication sur l'ensemble du
territoire donc c'est un média qui un
rôle absolument majeur et donc nous
devons nous préoccuper de la manière
dont il sera écouté dans les prochaines
années
ce qu'on voit quand on regarde
l'évolution des usages c'est que
contrairement à d'autres à un autre
média audiovisuel le poids de l'écoute
en direct reste très important
aujourd'hui c'est plus de 90% de
l'écoute
et on voit aussi que cette écoute se
fait à 80 % sur un support de diffusion
RCN donc avec l'AFM ça veut dire que ce
poids de l'écoute en direct est majeur
et on sait qui va rester très élevé dans
les prochaines années l'étude du
gouvernement britannique à laquelle
faisait référence le président de la com
ce projette à 15 ans et évalue plusieurs
scénarios au sein desquels les coûts en
direct va rester majoritaire parce que
la radio est un média d'accompagnement
et plus largement l'audio est un média
d'accompagnement donc on branche sans
s'arrêter pour savoir quel programme
choisir trop longuement comme on fait
pour la télévision
c'est prélaps sont importants parce que
ce qui est ça veut dire que ça diffusion
la diffusion du direct est un enjeu qui
est absolument essentiel pour le secteur
or ce qui était très bien dit c'est que
le réseau de l'AFM est saturé il est
aussi fragmenté et enfin il ne répond
plus aux usages d'aujourd'hui je vais
insister un peu sur ce point-là on sait
que dans les usages audio aujourd'hui on
a des plateformes qui diffusent de la
musique qui permettent de présenter la
pochette de l'album des données sur la
musique qu'on écoute sur le programme
qu'on écoute aujourd'hui le réseau FM et
sa diffusion est très décalée par
rapport à ces nouveaux standards
d'écoute qui sont ceux de l'audio ce qui
veut dire que si on se projette dans la
durée comment est-ce que la radio vous
va rester concurrentielle face à des
usages audio qui eux ont une modernité
dans leur code leur standard qui vont
être notre première concurrence dans les
années qui viennent